Adam Driver, welcome to our program.
Thank you.
Thank you very much.
Thanks for having me.
How difficult was it
for you to play Enzo?
What about him?
Well, I mean,
I feel the pressure with every job.
This one was,
you know,
because he was such an Italian icon,
an automotive
automotive icon,
but largely because it was Michael.
What I liked about the character
is that Michael's version of him
was that he was a racer first.
So he was calm on the surface,
but had a constant engine
going on underneath.
And what I love about
Michael in his films
is that
I feel like they're accessible
to everyone.
If you get into one of my cars,
you get in the wind,
but they're not dumbed down
where he insults
his audience intelligence
by telling them everything.
You have to you do have to do work
as an audience member.
It's not necessarily
a character,
a character
that's easily accessible or likable,
which I think is more true
to how things are in life.
So and and and just this
these moments in his films that are just,
you know, incredible cinema,
just beautiful, moving images.
Well, that's that's for damn sure.
It's a very beautiful look.
And Michael Michael Mann,
you're talking about the director
just for our audience.
I just before
I get to one of these pieces
of beautiful cinema and a clip,
I want to ask you.
What is it about Michael Mann
just for our audience?
Tell us, what are the films?
What is it about what he does
you've told us about
not dumbing down
and really making the audience work
and you love his genre.
Just give us a few that
that you really liked
and made you wanted to do this.
Well, I've actually,
after working with him, have gone
when I went back
when we were shooting
and watch his films,
I see Michael in all his films.
I see him in Heat and The Insider and
Last of The Mohicans and Thief
and the Common Thread.
I would,
I would say largely external, either
a lot about process and obsession
and commitment,
speaking generally in big themes.
But as an actor, I was surprised
at how much Michael is interested
in internal life.
In almost 90% of
his notes are internal life.
He doesn't
waste time with a lot of characters
coming on film
and explaining everything that they feel,
which I feel is often
you kind of get in scripts
is you can't, you can't guess.
There's no ambiguity.
You have to,
as a character, say
everything that you feel.
And I think that's
why his movies are so rich
and he has such
a sharp attention to detail.
And he is
relentless in this
in a quest for authenticity.
Tell me what sort of scenes here
match that?
I mean, you know, really the authenticity
knowing without actually telling you
in terms of this film.
Or in this film there
the engine sounds is something that
he is very particular about.
A lot of
some of the cars were the real thing.
And he would
you know, these are like $70,000,050.50
$50 million cars that were shipped there
and nine mikes were strapped to them
and driven down the tunnel
because you can't replicate the engine.
You kind of have to have the real thing.
So even in watching it, you you get the
we can't use the
the engine sounds of the other cars
that were crashing in the film.
So that kind of specificity
and not just recording it,
sitting idle on a
on a tarmac,
actually taking it down a tunnel
so you can get the sound
bouncing off the buildings is
is a perfect example in our movie.
That's amazing.
And you yourself are known
to be equally passionate
about getting things right,
about immersing yourself in roles.
I don't know. Are you method?
How do you describe what you do
and how you get
totally into the characters?
I you know, for me it's kind of like
it's it's not method.
It's,
you know, it's
kind of like moving to a new country.
And I felt this way about theater.
You move to a new country
and you have to adjust to the time.
So if you're in London,
I mean, here
if I went to London at the time,
our differences 5 hours
for the first couple of days,
it would feel like I feel tired.
But then after a few days,
just naturally by osmosis,
you just start to adjust to the time
and it becomes natural.
The same thing with the character.
I load up on as much information
as I can,
really to just control anxiety
as much as possible.
So I feel like there's not a stone
that I haven't overturned.
And then you move to a country
which is usually a film,
and then it's awkward
for a couple of days
and then just naturally
from wearing the costumes
or being on set
or the other actors
or piece of
technical thing or direction
that Michael has given you.
Then suddenly just being in that person's
shoes literally for,
you know, 14 hours a day
for months on end,
naturally, you just kind of adjust
your body, adjust your mindset, adjust.
And it's
that's my favorite part of acting.
It's, you know, forced empathy for,
you know, three or four months,
sometimes a year,
if you're
including prep in your in your life,
you know.
So that for me
is, yeah, it's not
it's kind of unconscious in a way.
So let's get back to the actual scenes.
You said something
a while back about
how Enzo is all these complex
different characteristics,
including not necessarily likable.
And I actually found that
to be very true.
And I thought that was part of the
I thought that was part of
what was compelling
as well as other things.
So I'm going to play a little clip.
This is not on the race course.
It's actually interaction
between you and Penelope Cruz,
who plays your wife, Laura, and she is
now going at you
over the death of your son.
You were supposed to save him.
You blame me for his death?
Yes. Yes.
Because you promised me you wouldn't die.
Everything I did.
Everything.
Table showing what calories he could eat,
what went in, what came out.
I graph the degrees of albuminuria,
the degrees of anxiety.
Mia diuresis.
I know more about nephritis
and dystrophy than cars.
Yes, I blame you.
I gave you because you let him die.
The father deluded himself.
The great engineer.
I will restore my son.
12th wealth doctors, Italian doctors.
But I could not.
I did not.
Is so raw and is so dramatic.
And.
And to see him as the,
you know, the race
car expert
and then getting into this
very personal situation.
Half the story
or maybe the most of the film
is about his personal relationship
with his wife,
who's his business partner
with his lover, who's the married,
the mother of his next son.
It's very, very personal.
Yeah.
Which is another thing
that I could say about what
I love about Michael's films.
And I probably should say
just also hedge
people's expectations that it very easily
could have been a movie
with a loose plot.
That's an excuse to look at.
Beautiful old Ferrari
driving at a beautiful time,
you know, in the world.
You know,
the late fifties in Italy is beautiful.
The costumes are beautiful.
But Michael's films are character driven.
He's he is committed and obsessed with
having three dimensional characters.
So hopefully
by the time something does happen
that you actually care, which seems to be
is honestly hard
to find in a lot of scripts.
This is a character driven movie.
First,
where the spectacle is, is I'm
avoiding all driving metaphors, but
it's easy to say it takes a backseat
to to what his his character study is.
And
and in a way they they all they
communicate with each other.
You know,
who cares if anyone crashes
if you don't really.
Ah, don't care about the people.
I want to ask you
because I always get surprised
when I think that you as a younger man
joined the Marines.
And I wonder
whether that gives you the intensity,
the discipline,
the connection with with raw reality
that you were able
to bring with you to Hollywood
and this profession?
I don't know.
I haven't analyzed it
very much other than I mean, apart of
as far as what intensity
I bring to perform, I will say that I'm
I look at a film set
no different than I did a gun team.
Obviously, the
the stakes are life and death in a
in the Marine Corps.
Whereas in the civilian world
or acting,
you're pretending that
they're life and death.
But the way the process of working on it
is, is is almost the exact same.
You know, it's
a group of people
trying to accomplish a mission
that's bigger than any one person.
You know,
you have a role
that is a part of the whole piece.
It's not about you.
And the better that you do your job,
it allows someone else
to do their job
to the best that they can.
You're battling,
you know, it's improvization.
There's a lot of pressure.
You're battling the elements.
You're you're battling time
and when under that
kind of intense pressure
and scrutiny, you you are in a
you have friendships and dynamics
that it's hard to explain to people
who are not there.
You know,
the crossover
between the military and acting,
especially as a group of people
doing this thing
that's bigger than any one person
really made sense to me.
And so I don't take it for granted.
I films of being in Indiana
could not have been more of
of science fiction,
that I would be a part of that world.
I had no connection to anyone
in the acting industry
and might as well have been an astronaut.
So I don't take it for granted
and have been the beneficiary of movies
that have given me images and moments
that will last my entire life.
So when we're shooting,
I don't take it lightly.
I think it's an incredible opportunity.
It's a document
that's going to last forever
that has the potential of finding
someone that is in a culture
that has nothing to do with mine
and hopefully would articulate a feeling
or give a similar moment
that will live with them
for the rest of their life.
What what
an amazing thing to be a part of.
I don't want to mess it up.